in China they're still building 90 000  quarantined facilities for sorry ninety  thousand individual boots pods for  people to to live in in major cities all  throughout China so so again these These  are camps that people are thrown in many  times not even for testing uh positive  many times for being around someone that  was maybe sick and other times for  criticizing the government people just  get thrown in these pods as we saw in  Australia people were thrown in there  without any tests without any close  contacts they were just arguing that  police officers the police officers had  had enough saying no two-week quarantine  you're done absolutely insane policies